so we have four numbers listed here what
I would like you to do is get out some
pencil and paper and pause this video
and see if you can order these numbers
from least to greatest so the least
would be at the left and then keep going
greater and greater greater until you
get to the greatest number so pause the
video and have a go with that all right
now let's tackle this together and the
way that I like to do it is I start at
the I guess you could say the most
significant place value or the largest
place value compare the numbers and then
keep moving to the right to smaller and
smaller place values so we can start in
the ones place this number has zero ones
this number has zero ones this number
has zero ones and that number has zero
ones so the ones place really doesn't
help us much but then we can move to the
tenths place this number has seven
tenths this number has zero tenths so
just from that we know that the second
number is less than the first number
this has seven tenths this as a zero
tenths it doesn't matter what's
happening in the places after that to
the right of that this number over here
also has seven tenths just like the
first number and this last number also
has seven tenths so we know from
comparing the the ones and then the
tenths place is that this number right
over here is the smallest of the four
numbers they all have zero ones but this
one also has zero tenths so I'll list
that here zero point zero seven four now
let's move to the hundredths place so
this number has zero hundredths we've
already used this number this number has
seven hundredths and then this number it
might not be obvious but the hundredths
place you can view as being a zero the
hundredths place you could just put a
zero there and not change the value so
this also has zero hundredths so these
three numbers same ones same tenths but
this number zero point seven seven has
seven hundredths while the other two had
zero hundredths so this is going to be
the largest of our four numbers this is
larger than these other two because of
what we see in the hundredths place it
doesn't matter what's happening in the
thousands place or anything beyond that
so we put the zero point seven seven
right
there and now we are tasked and we've
used this number and now we have to
compare these two numbers which were
equal in the ones tenths and hundredths
place so we have to go to the
thousandths place this number has 7
thousandths this number has 0
thousandths so this number is smaller
than this first number here so I'll
write this next zero point 7 and then
the third smallest or the next the
largest number is this one over here
zero point 7 0 7 and we're done so the
the main idea is you want to compare the
most significant place values the
largest place values first and then
based on that keep moving to the right
to compare less and less significant
place values